let's talk about something very special
that we have going on a viewer who has
been a member for a while he didn't ask
to be identified but I'm just going to
thank him as David not because that's my
name that's actually his name Pat was
like okay you call everybody David now
it does come on no his name really is
David he has prepaid for half of twelve
memberships memberships for a year
normally 60 bucks
david has prepaid $30 for 12 memberships
okay and these are now being made
available to people in our audience we
have 12 memberships available you just
pay the other 30 bucks okay david has
already paid 30 dollars for 12
memberships 12 people can now get a
membership for 30 dollars and you can
keep that rate for as long as you want
just get in touch with me okay go to
david pakman.com click on contact say
hey David I want one of Good Samaritan
David I'm clearly not Good Samaritan
David right when I say Good Samaritan
David I'm clearly talking about someone
else couldn't possibly be me I want one
of Good Samaritan David's 12 half-price
memberships I'll send you a code the
first 12 people 12 is gonna go quick
right yeah we returned what half a dozen
into a dozen yes I'd like to see it
become maybe a baker's dozen
oh yeah extra a piece of bread or
doughnut or whatever it is just you wait
and see what sort of shenanigans I'm
going to be pulling with these 12
memberships just you wait pad
so anyway 12 half-price memberships
thanks to longtime viewer David Wright
in if you want one of those and those
will count towards the 500 new financial
supporters we're trying to gain when we
left off at the end of the vacation I
think we were at about 160 or 170 or so
in our progress towards 500 new
financial supporters the idea is we want
to expand the show we want to add a new
staffer we want to make some
technological improvements we want to
reduce the amount of commercials on the
show we want to be able to a trade off
rotating break so that we can continue
producing shows during vacations and the
goal is 500 new financial supporters
there are three ways to contribute and
be one of those 500 number one is of
course membership David's 12 half-price
memberships count if you can afford to
pay full price by all means you can go
to david pakman.com slash membership if
you want a 40% discount
you can use the coupon code vote soon 18
that'll save you 40% that's available to
everybody if you want one of the half
price memberships 12 are available just
get in touch the second means by which
you can contribute to being one of the
500 new financial supporters is patreon
you go to patreon.com slash david pakman
show even if you contribute the minimum
which is a dollar a month it still
counts towards those 500 new supporters
thank you very much and lastly we are
part of the YouTube sponsorship beta
this is a new thing where you can
sponsor our channel on YouTube using the
blue text sponsor button on the channel
homepage and on most of our video pages
$4.99 a month has its own set of
benefits including a sponsors only icon
next to your name in comments and chats
sponsors only posts as well any of those
three methods the number is 500 total
membership patreon or YouTube
sponsorship we have surpassed 300 so we
are more than three-fifths of the way
there you prefer percentages we are more
than 60 percent of the way there
I don't know when what other ways I
could maybe break that down but anyway
we have fewer than 200 new supporters to
go we were getting very very close
membership patreon and YouTube
sponsorship and we do have twelve of
those half price memberships thanks to
longtime member David get in touch if
you want one of those twelve